[موسيقى]
اي بحث ياتي من خارج المنظومه حتى لو كان
ضاحي السعودي انا الان عبد الله لما اروح
لو اروح الى القصيم وحاول ادرس الاسلام
السياسي السني المجتمع راح يكون حضر معي
نفس الشيء لو تروح تدرس الفكر
اللي بيصير
انك راح تلاقي الكثيرين
البعض الذين يمثلهم تيارات معينه
يتوقفونك ويحاولون ان يمرروا
كل من يكتب الاسلام السياسي الشيعي وعن
حزب الله الحجاز ياتي ليقطي باسم توبي
الذي اخذ روايه جاهزه
وهذه اشكاليه كبيره لاحطها في عند توبي
يولام او لا يلام هذا شيء اخر ممكن نسميه
اغراء كمان الدكتور عبد الله بعض الباحثين
العرب وحتى السعوديه الا اذا وجد كتاب
وعليه دمغه باحث غربي او حتى الجامعه
الامريكيه وكذا هذا بحد ذاته يجعله همم
يشعر بالاطمئنان من ناحيه الصرامه العلميه
والمنهجيه ويمكن في شعور خفيف ببرستيج
[موسيقى]
انا بضرب بتاع الطريف
هو ذكر بالانجليزي
في شيخ انت ما الى حزب عفوا انتبه الى خط
الامام غير مسيئه سواء كان يحضر دروس
الخميني في النجف اسمها عبر الجليل ابن
مره